ja wir hatten in der ersten Vorlesung
ersten Teil heute uns noch mal Gedanken
gemacht über
den Begriff der Virtualität
und wir hatten interessante Fragen
aufgeworfen Ausgang von der
Begriffsgeschichte nämlich wie verhält
es sich
dort wo wir zum Beispiel ein physisches
Buch digitalisieren
ist es dann auch eine
virtuelle Realität die danach entsteht
wenn wir etwas digitalisieren also das
generelle Verhältnis von Virtualität und
Digitalisierung ist natürlich ganz
wichtig das ist auch der Grund warum
jetzt virtuelle Realität zum Zentrum
steht dank der Digitalisierung kann man
sich natürlich fragen was ist
Digitalisierung eine Technik eine
Technologie und auch
ein Medium das digitale können wir auch
als Medium verstehen
ist eine wäre eine Vorlesung für sich
das digitale auf seine philosophische
Bedeutung hinzu befragen genauer gesagt
die Digitalität das meint die digitalen
Lebenswelt da habe ich eine eigene
Vorlesung dazu gemacht da mache ich oben
rechts einen Youtube-Video ein Link zu
der Playlist rein können sich alles
nachhören nachsehen wir fragen wenn wir
uns mit der Digitalisierung unter der
Digitalität befassen heute ihr danach
wie sich das zur
Theorie
virtueller Realität behält das ist unser
Fokus heute ja und wir wollen da jetzt
auch gleich weitermachen und ich will
nur bei einem Punkt erwähnen
wenn wir ein Buch ein physisches
gedrucktes Buch digitalisieren und ein
digitales Buch haben ist das denn eine
virtuelle Realität ein virtuelles Buch
ist alles da seine was wird
digitalisieren schon damit gleich
virtuell ich habe ein Beispiel gebracht
wir
digitalisieren ein Elefanten
also wir bilden in digital ab wenn man
das ohne Digitalisierung versteht ist
natürlich immer die Frage ob das
wirklich Digitalisierung voll sind ist
aber angenommen wir tun das dann haben
wir eben ein digitales Abbild wir
erhalten häufig digitale Abbilder von
etwas das meint natürlich nicht den voll
sind von Digitalisierung sondern
Digitalisierung meint häufig dasjenige
oder digitale Transformation meint
dasjenige was wir hier Virtualisierungen
das heißt durch die Digitalisierung
erlangen wir neue Möglichkeiten und wir
können altes ersetzen oder zumindest
erweitern
also wenn wir jetzt so ein digitales
Bild von etwas machenden digitales Foto
nur digitale Abbilder erstellen dann hat
es sich natürlich um Simulationen beides
sind ein Bild simuliert die Wirklichkeit
in einer bestimmten Hinsicht unter dem
visuellen Gesichtspunkt einer
Perspektive und natürlich könnte man
jetzt auch ein Elefant digital ganz
nachbilden ich habe das Beispiel
gebracht in der videofolie wo es
Augmented Reality gegen Sie sich noch an
dem so an den augmented Zone
Einkaufszentrum wo plötzlich sein
eingeblendeter digital realisierter
Elefant muss man sagen
digitalen Mitteln und Medien ist ja ja
und realisiert worden umherläuft auch
dann würde ich sagen es ist kein
virtueller Elefant es ist ein
simulierter Elefant
anders verhält sich jetzt wenn wir ein
Buch digitalisieren weil wir damit ist
dann mit Zeichen zu tun haben und nicht
mehr nur mit Bildern ist ein Unterschied
ob ich Bilder digitalisiere oder Zeichen
digitalisiere wenn ich ein Buch
digitalisiere dann bilde ich nicht nur
die Zeichen ab ich simuliere nicht die
Zeichen die im Buch stehen sondern ich
realisiere sie oder ich übernehme sie
auf eine neue Weise weil die Referenz
der digitalen Zeichen nicht unbedingt in
erster Dinge die Referenz aufgeht
physischen Zeichen im Buch ist sind auf
die Bedeutung der Zeichen das ist der
Unterschied es geht nicht mehr um
bildverhältnisse dass das digitale Buch
das physische abbildet es sei denn es
handelt sich Bilder dann kann es wichtig
sein und Grafiken wenn es um Zeichen
geht die Bedeutung tragende Einheiten
sind dann geht es hier nicht mehr so
sehr um die Abbildung sondern um den
Sinn
und Bedeutung gleich bedeutet
also in dem Sinne des sinnesrede
der Unterschied ist jetzt der dass ich
sagen würde wenn wir ein physisches Buch
digitalisieren haben wir es schon eher
mit virtuelle Realität zu tun warum wir
simulieren nicht die Zeichen eines
gedruckten Buches weil die Referenz
anders ist an die Referenz geht auf
sozusagen
das was diese Mantik bedeutet vielleicht
auch die Referenz auf Dinge in der Welt
das wäre dann die Bedeutung nach Frege
also die Bezeichnung von Gegenständen
der Welt es dreht sich dann gar nicht
mehr um das abbildverhältnis des
physischen Buches sondern es geht um das
was mit diesen Zeichen bezeichnet wird
ausgedrückt wird und wenn ich jetzt
diese digitale Transformation des
physischen Buches Unternehmen dann
stelle ich fest dass ich mir ganz neue
Möglichkeiten bieten ich kann nämlich
ein digitalisiertes Buch ganz anders
verwenden und viel mehr im Sinne eines
Buches verwenden als ein physisches Buch
ich kann nämlich zum Beispiel gleich das
finden was mich interessiert sofern die
Zeichen digitalisiert vorliegen
UCR oder Optiker character ich kann eben
ganz gezielt nach bestimmten Wörtern
suchen ich kann die Zeichen auf eine
andere Weise anordnen lassen ich bin
nicht mehr gebunden an die Seiten
Darstellung regelmäßigen Buches sie
kennen das zum Beispiel vom Kindle haben
sie ein Kindle Lesegerät sie können das
ganz beliebig die Schriftgröße verändern
verändert sich natürlich auch die
Seitenzahl des Buches je größer die sind
die Schrift machen umso mehr Seiten
bekommt dieses Buch plötzlich also die
Seitenangabe spielt eigentlich keine
Rolle mehr bei einem digitalen Buch weil
es ja relativ ist von der zu
Schriftgröße das heißt sie lassen die
physischen Grenzen eines
normalen Buches hinter sich und erlangen
dadurch neue Möglichkeiten und diese
ganzen Charakteristiken die ich jetzt
gebracht habe nicht mehr bloßes Abbild
simulationsverhältnis neue Möglichkeiten
Unabhängigkeit von der physischen
Verfassung des Buches ein digitales Buch
geht auch nicht so schnell kaputt wie
ein physisches es kam die Frage auf wie
es ist mit der Dauer mit der
existenzauer die Existenz eines
digitalen Buches hängt natürlich von
anderen Faktoren ab als die Existenz
eines physischen Buches es gibt aber
gewisse analogen zum Beispiel kann ein
Buch von einem
unliebsamen Infekt zerstört werden
Bücher
und sowas überhaupt gibt oder von
anderen Lebewesen die sich dort häuslich
niedergelassen haben sowas ist wirklich
Milben
wir müssten sie jetzt Antiquariate und
antiquariare Fragen die
hier in der Marienstraße sich
niedergelassen haben die erzählen ihnen
ganze Geschichten darüber welche
Lebewesen oder auch welche
Temperatureinflüsse oder Umwelteinflüsse
physische Bücher zerstören können
Feuchtigkeit Schimmel oder
Feuer richtig Brand aber auch ganz
banale Dinge einfach sachgerechte
Lagerung macht diesen physischen Büchern
zu schaffen auf der anderen Seite wenn
wir bei den Insekten bleiben können
natürlich auch Viren Ihren PC zusetzen
und Dokumente und brauchbar werden
lassen sowas ist mir noch nie passiert
aber es soll es geben dass zum Beispiel
dann die gesamte Festplatte korrumpiert
wird die ganze Datenstruktur defekt wird
und dann können Sie auch das digitale
Buch vergessen ja also es ist Ton von
verschiedener Seite Gefahren die die
Existenz eines
physischen oder digitalen Buches an
einschränken können die Lebensdauer aber
die Bedingung sind doch andere Art viele
sagen jetzt neuerdings wir sollten doch
lieber wenn es um Archivierung geht auf
physische Medien setzen weil die einfach
längerfristig lebensfähiger sind die
sind beständiger wenn wir die richtig
lagern dann hält ein physisches Buch
können Sie nachlesen vielleicht 5000
Jahre ungefähr unter optimalen Bedingung
vielleicht noch länger das Papier je
nach Qualität wenn Chlor drin ist wenn
es vergeht wenn es lichtanfällig ist ins
chlor freigeschleicht ist jetzt
alterungsbeständig ist sie kennen diese
liegende Acht gibt es verschiedene
Papiersorten und wenn Sie jetzt ein Buch
aus dem 18 Jahrhundert nehmen das ist
natürlich nicht mehr 10.000 Jahre alt
war sehr wahrscheinlich ja weil die
Papierqualität einfach schlecht ist es
kommt zu Oxidationsprozessen und so
weiter und so fort äh jetzt sagen
trotzdem viele Menschen die in dieser
Wissenschaft beheimatet sind das ist
immer noch besser 10.000 Jahre alt als
eine Diskette weil eine Diskette
verliert ihre Speicherfähigkeit und auch
Ihre Daten nach einer ziemlich
überschaubaren Zeit können Sie nachlesen
vielleicht 50 Jahre sie müssen Glück
haben wenn Disketten die Sie vielleicht
noch haben lesbar sind echtes Problem
bei CD-ROMs verhält sich ähnlich auch
die sind nach einer Weile ob vielleicht
durch Witterungseinflüsse müsste man
genauer schauen nicht mehr so gut lesbar
obwohl ja eigentlich nicht jetzt
wirklich aus wirklich anfälligen
Materialien bestehen das sind ja nur so
kleine Erhebungen Vertiefungen drin die
eigentlich locker noch gelesen werden
können müssten jetzt kommt noch ein
anderes Problem dazu gelesen werden
können müssten es geht bei digitalen
Medien immer noch um Ausgabeformate was
bringt ihnen die stabilste floppy disk
wenn sie kein Gerät mehr haben was diese
lesen kann diese Medien das heißt wir
haben eine zusätzliche Abhängigkeit
der ich sage nicht die Existenz aber der
Ausgabe und es gibt natürlich bei
Büchern nicht sei denn sie verlernen die
Sprache sowas kann auch passieren dass
man irgendwann nicht mehr Latein kann
sowas ist absehbar und 50 Jahren nehme
ich an gar nicht schlimm es ist einfach
ein Faktum wird werden deutsche Schüler
wahrscheinlich kein Latein mehr können
oder zumindest nicht mehr so gut dass
sie die ganze
Tradition verstehen müssen Sie auch
nicht aber es wird immer schwieriger
sein womöglich
Forschenden Forscher auszubilden die das
noch übersetzen können macht nichts
werden sie in 50 Jahren sagen künstliche
Intelligenz kann mittlerweile auch
perfekt latein
ist eine andere Frage ob wir uns da ganz
auf künstlichen Intelligenz verlassen
können ich wollte jetzt nur die Probleme
darstellen die Existenz betreffen
einerseits ist digitale
virtuelle Realität
unanfälliger physisch andererseits
medial
medial wird abhängiger von
Elektronik von Technik von Technologie
man wird weniger abhängig von physischen
Witterungsumständen sie können auch
Dokumente in die Cloud laden dann wissen
sie natürlich nicht was damit gemacht
wird ja also sie vermitteln immer mehr
dieses Objekt während sie ein Buch das
in der Hand haben eigentlich nur durch
das oder die den Inhalt des Buches nur
durch das Papier vermittelt bekommen die
Vermittlungsinstanz ist einstellig das
Papier das Buch vermittelt den Inhalt
des Papier vermittelt den Inhalt an Sie
wenn Sie jetzt an eine eine virtuelle
Realität digitales Buch das wird
vermittelt durch das Ausgabegerät das
wird vermittelt durch verschiedene
Bestandteile über Strom und so weiter
und so fort die Abhängigkeiten sind viel
größer
Abhängigkeit größere Abhängigkeit heißt
aber nicht automatisch geringere und
biologische Signifikanz das ist ein
Fehlschluss ja auch ihre mentalen
Eigenschaften ihre Gedanken die sie
hoffentlich gerade sich zu diesem Thema
machen
egal sie dürfen sich natürlich Gedanken
machen wozu sie wollen die Gedanken sind
frei aber ihre Gedanken die sie gerade
wohl denken die sind auch hochgradig
abhängig sind ganz verschiedene Dinge
die sind abhängig von ihrer lebendigen
Funktion ihrem Körper Organismus diesen
abhängig von ganz vielen Faktoren
ihr Gehirn muss genug Nahrung haben ja
und so weiter und so fort normalerweise
funktioniert es zum Glück aber damit sie
mal wirklich denken können musste viel
passieren natürlich auch evolutionär
aber auch bei Ihnen und mir als
Individuen und trotzdem würden wir sagen
sind die das ist das irgendwie was wir
denken irgendwie eigenständig sie würden
nicht sagen mein Gedanke dass irgendwas
jetzt der Fall ist dass das Wetter
schöner sein könnte ist ein Gedanke der
ist eigentlich zurückzuführen auf
meine Gehirnstruktur auf meine
neuronalen Vorgänge letztendlich davon
dass ich genug gegessen habe es würden
sie doch nicht sagen dass sie dadurch
den Gedanken erklären können dass genau
dasselbe wie mit der Sinfonie dass ich
die erkläre dass sie aus schalbe steht
also das sind von nie damit sind es Sinn
von die höheren und vor allem verstehen
müssen ganz Orchester anreisen dann
müssen die Leute gut ernährt sein sie
müssen gesund sein und so weiter und
sofort die Akustik muss gut sein aber
darin geht doch nicht die Bedeutung des
Telefonie auch das sind umständlich die
notwendige Bedingung sind das vielleicht
die sind von die aufgeführt werden kann
aber eine sind von die besteht eben
nicht nur in diesen Umständen genauso
bestehen ihre die der besteht der Gehalt
und die Bedeutung ihre Gedanken nicht
darin dass sie jetzt gerade genug zu
essen haben oder dass einfach da
Neuronen Feuer das ist notwendig aber
sie könnten die Gedanken auch auf ganz
andere Weise vielleicht realisieren
vielleicht auch mal auf Basis von
Silizium Chips zumindest diskutiert
also das war so ein kleiner Rückblick
auf die ersten Annäherung an die
virtuelle Realität die Ontologie die
heute im Zentrum steht und jetzt kommen
wir endlich zu den aktuellen Themen zu
dem aktuellen Theorien virtuelle
Realität auf dem Markt der Philosophie
oder der Medienwissenschaften oder was
auch immer es gibt ja noch keine
eindeutige Zuständigkeit ich möchte
Ihnen hier von Michael Heim das Buch an
physics of virtual reality vorstellen
hier sehen sie haben wir gestern schon
kurz diskutiert einen
futuristischen nach Maßstäben der 90er
Jahre futuristischen Handschuh grün und
dahinter ein ja fast schon bedrohlich
oder zumindest seltsam
rothackig glänzen oder leuchtendes
Gesicht
ja es hat hier wie Sie sehen etwas ganz
und gar nicht lebensweltliches was
dieses Buch Cover zeigt wenn sie in dem
Handbuch Virtualität lesen dass
virtuelle Realität angekommen ist oder
Virtualität Teil unserer Lebenswelt ist
dann würde ich sagen ja aber dazu
gehören nicht so komische glänzende
grüne Handschuhe das ist nicht Teil
unseren Lebensmittel soll es auch nicht
sein sie sehen Anfang der 90er war
virtuelle Realität noch eine Sache von
Nerds von
eskapistinnen und skapisten es gab
vielleicht auf der Welt eine Handvoll
den 80ern von wie auch Systemen das ist
nicht lebenswert das ist
es Kapitalismus das ist
Technokratie
es ist nichts was unseren Alltag
betrifft sind
Experiment interessant Experimente wir
wollen jetzt mal lesen was diese Michael
Heim dazu sagt und zwar was seine erste
Erfahrung mit virtueller Realität
also er hat 1989 zu ersten Mal virtuelle
Realität betreten
before screen with
Keyboards in der computer generated
Computer
er war nicht mehr außerhalb des
Computers der Computer als Medium war
nichts mehr was uns entgegenstand
sondern wir waren immer sie involviert
in die Technik ist natürlich eine ganz
neue phänomenologische Erfahrung die
Phänomenologie der virtuellen Realität
ist auch ein ganz spannendes Thema ich
glaube allerdings nicht dass sie uns
letzt gültigen Aufschluss über das Wesen
gibt also wir müssen uns eher
begrifflich nehmen das wollen wir heute
auch tun aber als erstes Ernährung fängt
das ganz hilfreich und hier das habe ich
fett markiert mein philosophischer sei
es nur Graf spielte verrückt
also wo ist jetzt Realität wo ist wo ist
Simulation wo es Illusion wo bin ich wo
ist oben unten innen außen gibt es
überhaupt noch Räumlichkeit kann ich was
anfassen ist das echt nicht so müssen
sich das vorstellen deswegen finde ich
dieses Schilderung sehr treffen um die
Unterlage confusion genauer darzustellen
die wir ja schon diskutiert haben und
die sie alle hier nicht eingeschlossen
und die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer auf
Youtube wahrscheinlich auch erleben
werden wenn Sie diese Vorlesung folgen
oder sich überhaupt mit dem Begriff
virtuelle Realität befassen es ist so
dass wir eine eine Desorientierung erst
bekommen
also eine ja
vollständige
aggressive
Ersatz Realität surrogate
ist es als jetzt hier eine nebenwelt die
er hier uns schildert wie schildert er
sie er schildert sie in grellen Farben
das zeigt natürlich auch schon das Cover
giftgrün und
waren Signal rot
das ist etwas was unheimlich ist und
auch was irgendwie ein bisschen ja
aggressiv vielleicht wirken kann für
mich wirkt ja dieses Cover wie das Kabel
eines Horrorfilms muss ich sagen ja
irgendwie der Mörder mit dem grünen
Handschuhe oder sowas ja oder die
Mörderin Mann ja also die Eindrücke von
virtuelle Realität sind erstmal
ja ihr erschreckend
Orientierungslosigkeit Erstaunen
überhaupt Erstaunen ist ja auch eine Uhr
Haltung des Philosophen dass man
erstaunt griechisch Platon traumat sehen
das Staunen über ja über was über die
Welt und die Wirklichkeit muss man
dahingestellt sein lassen das ist auf
jeden Fall finde ich kann man wirklich
sehr gut übertragen auf die klassischen
philosophischen Motive die jetzt
revitalisiert werden durch diese neue
Technologie deswegen kann man schön am
Paradigma der Wirtschaft Realität oder
überhaupt ein paradigner der
Digitalisierung oder der Medien
gebraucht viele philosophischen Probleme
neu durchdenken und durchspielen das
macht auch David scharners auf den wir
gleich noch genauer eingehen werden
möchte noch ein Zitat bringen
er sagt komplett
da wir vollständig immer sie in die
virtuelle Welt einbezogen werden oder
eintreten im Meere heißt ein tauchen
genauer gesagt das hat ein tauchen ähm
konstitutiert virtuelle Realität eine
neue Form menschliche Erfahrung
Konstitution ist natürlich ein
ontologischer Begriff den wir heute im
Laufe der Vorlesung noch genauer
diskutieren müssen er sagt jetzt damit
unsere Bewegung bewirkt oder Ursache
oder erzeugt vielleicht erzeugt oder
vielleicht bewirkt egal eine neue
Erfahrung wird dadurch hervorgerufen
er bringt hier als
Anwendungsbereiche Filmtheater und
Literatur die
ein ähnliche Bedeutung hatten in der
Vergangenheit also virtuelle Realität
als neues Leitmedium als neues Paradigma
so wie die Literatur des Theater es
waren stellen sich mal die antiken
Griechen und Griechen vor 600 vor
Christus wenn die zum ersten Tag gehört
dir saßen in einem Theater das muss für
die unglaublich aufregen gewesen sein ja
so vor cles und so weiter die ganzen
Tragödien oder auch Komödien das muss
für die nicht Medien gewohnt Menschen
die hat mir keine Medien in diesem Sinne
die hatten vielleicht mündliche
Tradition ja Möglichkeit ist ein Medium
die hatten vielleicht erste
Schriftlichkeit viele waren alle
Alphabeten die konnten eben nur reden
aber nicht lesen oder schreiben
jetzt gibt es ein neues Medium des
Theater da wird Mündlichkeit auf eine
Künstlichkeit künstliche Form in einem
bestimmten künstlichen Raum
fiktiv zum Ziel der Fiktion gebraucht
das unerhört und natürlich auch wenn man
dann mal Alphabet hin und Alphabet ist
die Literatur Romane als in Deutschland
in Mitteleuropa die
Alphabetisierungsrate stieg im 18
Jahrhundert und Leute dann lesen konnten
und zum ersten Mal Roman gelesen haben
es muss ja für die überwältigen gewesen
sein da wirklich in eine neue Welt
einzudringen und ähnlich könnte das
jetzt auf unsere wirken die wir ja im
ideal verwöhnt sind und die wir ja alle
lesen können und auch durch das
Fernsehen auch Fernsehen genau dasselbe
dasselbe neue Paradigma Fernsehtechnik
ja was wie das auf die Menschen wirkte
dass man bewegtes Bild zu sehen und
jetzt plötzlich dieses Eintauchen in
diese künstliche Welt das muss natürlich
auch unglaublichen Effekt gehabt haben
den beschreibt er wir müssen dabei sagen
hier geht's bisher nicht um virtual
Realität so wie wir sie hier verstehen
wollen er hat kein ontologischen Begriff
virtuelle Realität er spricht eigentlich
nur von Erfahrungen komplexe
Simulationen Erfahrungen vollständigen
eintauchen das ist eine psychologische
Beschreibung phänomenologische
Beschreibung sagt aber erstmal noch gar
nichts über die Ontologie virtuelle
Realität außer nur da etwas darüber wie
wir uns fühlen wenn wir in eine
künstliche vollständige simulierte Welt
eintreten
deswegen müssen wir ein bisschen
kritisch sein was diesen Titel anbelangt
Melder physics of virtual reality was
meint ihr hier mit Metaphysik er spricht
hier nur von Erfahrung es mag eine
metaphysische Erfahrung sein als eine
Erfahrung die irgendwie
völlig verändert es gibt transformativ
Erfahrungen Menschen sprechen davon in
bestimmten Situationen wo sie zu neuen
Menschen werden weil sie etwas erfahren
haben so könnte man die Metaphysik
verstehen
aber es ist keine Ontologie in dem Sinne
wie wir sie hier heute unternehmen
wollen
Virtual Reality changes Relation zu
Informationen fundamental way
it is the first intellektuelle
technology
active use of the party in the search of
knowledge jetzt finde ich es mal ein
bisschen philosophische ausgedrückt
jetzt haben wir nämlich hier eine
zumindest
epistemologische genauer gesagt Aussage
über virtuelle Realität aber immer noch
keine ontologische
er sagt sie es verändert dieses Medium
der immersiven des immersiv Eindringens
Eintauchens des verändert unsere
Verhältnis zu Informationen es ist die
erste intellektuelle
Technologie die es erlaubt und dein
Körper aktiv für die Suche nach Wissen
einzusetzen denken sie zurück an Apple
Vision pro wo die Person und ihren
Händen nur etwas macht und schon scrollt
sie oder navigiert sie
Cyberspace die Navigation im Cyberspace
herum nur durch den Einsatz des Körpers
der durch
Sensoren natürlich völlig erfasst
hat er natürlich noch nicht vor Augen
gehabt
aber das liegt genau auf dieser Linie
also unser Körper hatte ich ja auch
gesagt wird in der virtuellen Realität
zu einem Medium der gesamte Körper
idealerweise wir brauchen gar nicht mehr
die Handschuhe unbedingt und die
Handschuhe geben nur unseren Händen
Ausdruck aber es ist unser Körper der
damit interagiert und das finde ich
jetzt aus Sicht eines ontologischen
Begriffs virtuelle Realität schon viel
spannender als nur eine Beschreibung
dessen der sich anfühlt es geht also ein
anderes wissensverhältnis durch unseren
Körper durch die neue Technologie
er hat dann ein weiteres Buch
geschrieben fünf Jahre später mit dem
Titel virtual reality
schöner Titel
müssen wir nur Fragen meinte damit
wirklich Realismus in dem Sinne das
virtuelle Realität
real ist als seine eigene Realität
darstellt das sagt jetzt folgendes was
ich etwas enttäuschend finde aus
ontologische Perspektiven Virtual
Reality ist ein art formsibility and the
way of living with new technology
okay ja eine Kunstform eine
Empfänglichkeit Sensibilität ein Weg
eine Weise mit neuer Technologie zu
leben
immerhin fast er damit die
lebensweltlich Einsicht die wir im
Handbuch Virtualität vermittelt bekommen
haben dort stand der virtuelle Realität
oder Virtualität ist Teil unserer
Lebenswelt geworden wenn das damit meint
kann man das natürlich Realismus nennen
aber er meinte er den alltäglichen
Umgang mit dieser Technologie
und jetzt möchte er sich aber ein
bisschen abgrenzen von bloßer Simulation
und Illusion er sagt when we talk about
virtual reality we have to keep in mind
that is indeed at technology not
simplyabulous ID also kein bloßes
Modewort er hat hier nur eine
technologischen Zugriff zur Zugang zur
virtuellen Realität keinen ontologischen
ja das ist alles aus dem Perspektive
eines
experimentierfreudigen Kalifornien
vielleicht
geschrieben so wie man sie sich eben bei
Google heute wurscht keine Ontologie
eine Technologie
ist not a state of
okay also er möchte sich abgrenzen von
Auffassungen virtuelle Realität die
sagen dass es eine illusionszeit er sagt
es ist mehr als eine Illusion oder eine
Halluzination es ist auch nicht nur ein
psychischer Bewusstseinszustand der wäre
ja relativ und auch kein loser
Drogentrip Virtual Reality ist
science ok also ein neues Feld eröffnet
sich für die angewandte Wissenschaft
also ganz klar technologischer Blick auf
virtuelle Realität
reality
bilanzure xxpresses and readforce many
of the prodigieren
also es geht am Ende darum dass diese
virtuelle Realität sich auf unsere
Kultur auswirken kann er unternimmt die
also eine
technokulturanalyse
die eben manche Erfahrungen verstärken
kann
die kulturell sind
und zwar wird jetzt hier die Fischer
real das künstliche mit dem realen
vermischt und das künstliche
hergestellte mit den natürlichen
also auch jedes Ziel virtuell soll eine
Vermischung des künstlichen mit dem
realen bedeuten des in unserem Alltag
Bedeutung erlangt das ist für ihn
virtueller Realismus das heißt
Simulationstechnik Technik Betonung auf
Technik nimmt immer mehr Einfluss auf
unsere Lebenswelt sie vermischt sich mit
unseren herkömmlichen Kulturformen
eröffnet neue Möglichkeiten der
Erfahrung und das ist das realistische
da ne einfach lebenswerten die Bedeutung
von technisch erzeugen komplexen
Simulationssystem
obwohl er ja in den vorherigen Zitat
sagte
er möchte es nicht nur als Simulation
verstehen oder Halluzination zum als
eine Suche nach Wissen das hat also
durchaus einen gewissen
realistischen Ansatz nicht bloß
illusiv oder halluzinativ aber doch
simulativ das kann man sich fragen ist
eine Simulation
ontologisch
stärker als eine Illusion ich würde
sagen schon was ist der Grund eine
Simulation orientiert sich an der
Realität sie bildet sie ab nicht perfekt
sonst wäre es ja eine Duplikation aber
sie kommt ihr ziemlich nahe aber eine
Simulation will gar nicht die Realität
duplizieren weil sie keine Simulation
mehr wir nutzen Simulation ja nur um uns
zu fokussieren auf bestimmt Aspekte zum
Beispiel Strömungsdynamik von Fahrzeugen
simulieren dann eben bestimmte Aspekte
eines Autos nicht zum Beispiel uns
unbedingt die formt die Form schon aber
nicht die Farbe zum Beispiel wenn wir
die Strömungsdynamik simulieren ist die
Form wichtig andere Faktoren auch
wichtig Geschwindigkeit und so weiter
aber die Farbe des Autos ist völlig
irrelevant die müssen wir nicht
simulieren das Auto kann in der
Simulation ein Prototyp sein eine graue
Maus völlig egal
das heißt wir sehen er hat hier den Raum
offen gehalten für Simulation er sagt
also virtuelle realismus ist kompatibel
mit Simulation
dennoch würde ich dagegen Antworten ist
eine Simulation nie die Realität
wenn sie jetzt zum Arzt gehen
zuerst hingehen sie haben Zahnschmerzen
und sagen ich glaube ich sie müssen mal
nachschauen ich glaube der Zahn muss
gezogen werden dann sagt in die Ärztin
wunderbar wir simulieren jetzt hier dass
ich ihn den Zahn ziehen das simuliert
ist am PC ich simuliert
wird immer noch weh und der ist immer
noch drin da können Sie noch so viel
simulieren ja
das heißt Realismus im harten Sinne ist
es nicht was er jetzt hier wird ist nur
realistisch
wenn es hart auf hart kommt wollen sie
keine Simulation können Sie auch mit
zwischenmenschlichen Dingen sehen sie
wollen ja nicht eine geliebte Person nur
simulativ lieben da sie dann der Person
sagt ich simuliere gerade dich zu lieben
aber ich hoffe es gefällt dir trotzdem
ja da wird in die andere Person sagen
ich glaube du spinnst ja bestenfalls ja
und zwar zu Recht also Simulation ist
schön und gut und man redet auch
heutzutage immer von Simulationen und so
weiter und so fort das alles toll aber
die Wirklichkeit ist sie noch lange
wir können mit Simulation sehr viel
erreichen sehr viele Dinge bewirken aber
wir müssen sie immer noch unterscheiden
von Realität genauso ist Chat GPT eine
gute Simulation von rationaler
vernünftiger Kommunikation aber wie es
zurecht gesagt wurde wenn es dann z.B
momentan darum geht die korrekten
Quellen genannt bekommen da wird dann
was aufgetischt was auf den ersten Blick
sehr realistisch wird aber es ist
letztendlich große Fake ja also es
sollen einfach getäuscht werden und da
sehen sie Simulation und Illusion sind
nicht so weit voneinander entfernen
möchte uns auch manchmal in der Illusion
lassen dass wir hier ist mit einem
rationalen
gegenüber zu tun hätten ja und es kann
durchaus sein dass irgendwann mit
jetchibiti auch den Eindruck der
Immersion haben oblader kommen aber
tolle Antworten ich kann da toll chatten
aber es ist nicht immer so aber es ist
nicht die Realität ich kommuniziere
nicht wirklich mit einem rationalen
Subjekt es wird mir nur so vorgegeben es
wird nur so getan das heißt es wird
simuliert schlimmstenfalls auch werde
ich
an einer Illusion getäuscht wenn ich
irgendwann glaube das sei die
Wirklichkeit sie sehen die digitalen
Medien eröffnen uns viele Möglichkeiten
aber sie erfordern auch dass wir
kritisch mit ihm umgehen und Simulation
von Realität fein säuberlich
auseinanderhalten was immer schwieriger
wird vielleicht haben Sie schon mal
etwas von dem Phänomen ist deep Fake
gehört die Fake das ist also ein
Vermögen von künstliche Intelligenz dass
die hochgradig realistisch
zum Beispiel auch
ja neue Bilder neue Situationen erzeugen
können Donald Trump als Putzmann gab es
im Spiegel vor zwei Wochen oder auch
bewegte Bilder wo Donald Trump irgendwas
in den Mund gelegt wird das sieht so aus
als würde es wirklich sagen natürlich
alles großes Simulation und in die
letzte Hinsicht weil sie eine Absicht
verfolgen und zu täuschen sind es auch
Illusionen also hier muss man ganz
einfach aufpassen und darf die Begriffe
nicht also schnell durcheinander bringen
das reale sollte wirklich noch dem
realen Vorbehalt bleiben und nicht nur
dem realistischen sonst drohen wir eine
bloße modephilosophie zu entwerfen ob
jetzt das eine modephilosophie ist
möchte ich nicht hier diskutieren aber
ich möchte es durchaus problematisieren
dass wir nicht allzu schnell hier von
Realismus sprechen sollten das muss mir
stärker verstehen auch aus ethischer
Hinsicht weil sonst verwechseln wir
Simulation Illusion mit der Realität das
hat aus ethischer Hinsicht gravierende
Konsequenzen die sagen ich habe doch nur
simuliert dich zu bestehlen oder ob sie
sagen ich habe dich wirklich bestohlen
und große Unterschied
ein jedenfalls amerikanischer ja
Kultur Philosoph
Technik enthusiast
Technik Pionier das sind alles sehr
interessante Persönlichkeiten die viel
Erfahrung auf diesem Feld aufweisen hat
auch ein Buch geschrieben zu diesem
Thema
reality und er
sagt dazu auch ganz interessante
scient TV
Technologien
1995 93 gesagt die neue Erfahrung
deshalb was ganz neues Paradies machen
illusions der sagt jetzt plötzlich
illusions Michael Heim hat gesagt dass
keine Illusion Simulation schon aber
nicht Illusion
place perhaps in the fantastical
Aliens researching oder human being is
in the times of nation das hatte
wiederum Michael Heim gesagt Michael
Heim hatte gesagt hier geht's darum mit
unserem Körper ein neues systemisches
Verhältnis zu realisieren Sie
jetzt hier auch never
Beauty Penis
niemals zuvor war ein Mädchen so
in der Lage so Schönheit aber auch so
verletzbar oder so bedroht von
sonderartigkeit oder
creepiness von Unheimlichkeit
Virtual Reality ist
dem kann ich nur zustimmen ja also
Virtualität was auch immer wir jetzt
darunter verstehen wird uns testen auch
wenn wir es realistisch also real stehen
wie in diesem dieser Vorlesung unter
logisch wird sie uns testen und sie wird
auch unseren Charakter erweitern durch
Avatar und so weiter das sind natürlich
alles
Zukunftsaussagen achten Sie auf die
Formulierung natürlich ist es eine
zukunftige Projektion aber ist natürlich
auch eine
These also eine Aussage ihren
Wahrheitswert aber sich auf die Zukunft
bezieht und bei solchen Formulierung
müssen wir als Philosophen und
Philosophen ein bisschen aufpassen es
geht hier nicht eine Philosophie und
Zukunft Spekulation ist nicht unsere
Aufgabe er kann das schon machen aber
wenn wir hier Zukunft Spekulation als
Philosophie ausgeben dann trifft das zu
was Jürgen Mittelstraße als
modephilosophie bezeichnet hat dann
werden wir Mode ich will nicht sagen
dass er einer ist aber wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir hier nicht nur
Zukunft Spekulation äußern und als
Philosophie verkaufen
das
virtuelle ist das ideale
im Gegensatz zum realen
Technologie wird vermischt mit
Hippie
müsst Hippie Kultur und Mystic obwohl es
eigentlich
gar nichts mit müsste ich so zu tun
Hightech und Stream Traum zugleich also
virtuelle Realität ist ein Medium was
alles vermischt sozusagen ja
alles zu gleichen Zeit ja wenn das alles
zu gleichen Zeit ist aber auch nicht
haben wir dann am Ende nicht wieder eine
confusion von dem wir uns eigentlich
lösen oder befreien wollten hilft der
hier uns weiter einen eine Ontologie
virtuelle Realität entwickeln wenn er
sagt es sei das ideale was im Gegensatz
zum realen stehen ja da haben wir wieder
ein Anti Realismus eigentlich bezüglich
Virtualität nur eine erfahrungsform auch
das hilft uns eigentlich auf der Suche
nach der Onkologie virtuelle Realität
nicht weiter zu einem Mädchen
Philosophie
und jetzt gibt er uns ein paar
Definitionen genau genommen gibt der uns
52 Definitionen meines Wissens über 50
in diesem Buch ich kann jetzt nicht alle
Definitionen
hier präsentieren zumal es eigentlich
gar keine Definitionen sind es sind
eigentlich nur Charakterisierung weil
damit wird virtuelle Realität definieren
müssten oder könnten müssten wir
notwendig und hinreichende Kriterien
angeben machte ja aber nicht er
verwendet also Definition eher ein
bisschen im schwächeren Sinn und jetzt
schauen wir mal was er sagt first
Definition
Art Cinema Jazz programming
okay also eine
Kunstform des 21 jahrhunderts die
verwirbt drei große Kunstform des 20
Jahresprogramm
jetzt gleich ich möchte jetzt die
Definition vorstellen dann diskutieren
darüber inwiefern sie das überzeugen
finden wir müssen gerade noch weiter das
durchgehen dann wird man die
Aufzeichnung stoppen Zecken we are
Definition
all the Wild West
virtuelle ein Wilder Westen der
virtuellen Welt wird heller Wilder
Westen
of the interface between App person and
the physical environment with an
interface to simulated in wirevent so
viel dazu noch eine fünfte und dann
diskutierer
image of a persons sensory and Motors
ORF your like an Inversion das finde ich
sehr spannend die Inversion die
Umkehrung die Umdrehung einer Person
es müssen aber mal wirklich drüber
diskutieren weil so können wir das
natürlich nicht stehen lassen als gute
kritische Philosophen und Philosophen
und ich werde jetzt auch die
Aufzeichnung entsprechend stoppen
ja wir haben gesehen
bringt interessante Definitionen es sind
aber eigentlich genauer gesagt nur
Charakterisierungen und wir haben
gesehen diese Definition stehen
eigentlich im Gegensatz teilweise auch
zu den von Michael heim
weil Michael hatte gesagt dass virtuelle
Realität keine Illusion ist und Germania
sagt das ist eine Illusion
wenn es aber eine Illusion ist dann ist
sie immerhin Objektiv geteilt
unten sagt er das in der 23 Definition
also es ist wie ein Drogentrip das hatte
auch Michael Heim verneint
aber es ist ein objektiver oder genauer
gesagt intersubjektiven Trip also alle
erleben das selbe können sich darüber
auch unterhalten das ändert aber nichts
daran dass es eben eine objektive
Illusion ist sowas soll es auch geben
Objektiv Illusionen sind nicht weniger
illusorisch nur weil sie objektiv
verschiedenen Subjekten eingegeben
werden die sich darüber einig sein
können dass sie jetzt etwas illusorisch
sind nichts daran das ist am Ende doch
eine Illusion ist ja aber es ist
zumindest auf dem Weg zu einem starken
stabilen Begriff virtuelle Realität weil
es eben eine Objektivität durch
Intersubjektivität hat und es ist nicht
rein individualistisch subjektiv relativ
so wie es zum Beispiel beim Drogentrip
der Fall und diese Objektivität bekommen
wir auch durch die Technologie durch die
Vergleichbarkeit die Koordination der
Illusion wir bekommen nämlich alle nicht
nur derselbe eingegeben sondern die
Eingabe der Illusion wird auch
koordiniert dass wir zur selben Zeit an
derselben Stelle das sehen dass wir uns
darüber einigen können also findet schon
seine schwache Objektive
konstitutionsleistung statt die aber
noch zu schwach ist um wirklich
ontologische virtuelle Realität so wie
wir sie hier erarbeiten wollen zu
erzielen
geht es weiter zu David scharmas david
charmers ist hervorgetreten in der
Philosophie durch Überlegung
Untersuchungen zu Philosophie des
Geistes zu Natur des Selbstbewusstseins
und er ist ein starker Kritiker von
reduktionistischen Auffassungen wonach
wir
bewusstseinsqualitäten durch neuronale
Vorgänge
hinreichend erklären können es ist
ziemlich einleuchtend wenn ich eine
rotweinnehmung habe oder mir etwas als
etwas erscheint ich eine Stimmung habe
in einer Stimmung um mich befindet dann
ist es nicht dasselbe wie der
Gehirnzustand der diese Stimmung
verursacht ja also er ist sicherlich
konstituiert diese also die Empfindung
diese quale dieses Qualle dieses wir
diese wie Empfindungen ist verursacht
durch den organische Strukturen aber sie
kann nicht vollständig erklärt werden
durch diese
organische Strukturen ihre Aktivität
sonst geht die mich oder gerade dadurch
ginge dieser
qualitative Charakter verloren ähnlich
hatte guter Weg kritisiert dass wir
leben nicht nur chemikalisch chemisch
oder physikalisch oder biologistisch
verstehen können er hat gesagt
Virtualität ist das was Leben bezeichnet
ich fasse das jetzt einfach mal so ein
bisschen aufwärts als was
anti-reduktionistisches als ein
anti-reduktionistischen Zug den
virtuelle Realität aufweist und der wird
charmas hat in seinem Buch reality place
ich stelle ihn gleich noch das Cover
genau vor ein paar ganz bekannte
Beispiele gebracht aus der Welt und
Kulturgeschichte
alle Nationen hier ist jetzt erstmal
hier zum Ziel Butterfly dream
was
a butterfly dreaming
zielt
ja bitte hier da haben wir die Experten
ja aber der Sinn den verstehen sie wer
träumt jetzt was ja
sie kennen das ist unser Leben nur ein
Traum
das ein
MS themologisches Problem ja was ist
jetzt Realität ist das hier Realität ist
es wirklich so das ist nur ein Traum es
war Illusion
ernährt sich allernährt sich also über
Traum
Überlegungen epistomologische Probleme
unter anderem den Begriff der virtuellen
Realität wir haben noch ein Beispiel wie
Schnur overse Seas nachradars
Transformation
in the style of Rick and Morty kennt
jemand Rick and Morty
also hier geht's also um auch seine
Eingabe
[Musik]
um eine Simulation natürlich die sitzen
in einer anderen Welt und das dritte
Playhouse Cave in the 20 century haben
wir schon gesehen hier werden bekommen
Leute etwas eingegeben befinden sich
aber nur in einer Höhle
und jetzt müssen wir das Ganze mal
genauer analysieren wenn sie dich das
Cover genau anschauen stellen sie
vielleicht sogar aus der Ferne fest auf
Youtube besser dass hier das ganze
verpixelt sehen Sie das hier wenn es
verpixeln hier oben ist es schön hier
ist auch verpixelt das sehen sie glaube
ich hier und hier ist es schön
realistisch das ist natürlich liegt
natürlich nahe dass das virtuelle mit
dem digitalen Verbindung steht obwohl es
nicht dasselbe ist nicht alles was
digitalisiert ist ist virtuell und nicht
alles
es gibt auch eben virtuelle Realitäten
die nicht digitalisiert sind ja also es
ist einfach unabhängig voneinander aber
wir können durch digitale Technik sehr
gut und sehr lebensweltlich eingängig
virtuelle Realität erzeugen so muss man
das Verhältnis bestimmen glaube ich
also also der first question Race bei
brauchen
diesen chinesischen
Butterfly Schmetterlings Traum betrifft
das wissen
als die epistemische Frage is the
knowledge question can we know weather
second question Race better
transformations reality all Collie the
reality question
concerns Valley in Wert alle
question
wir müssen hier natürlich schon durch
das Setting jetzt feststellen er
versteht virtuelle Welten als simuliert
obwohl er hier fragt sind sie real,-
unterscheidet zwischen
illusorischen Welten und simuliert
der Ansatz ist aber der dass er hier ein
ganz stark auf die Idee der perfekten
Simulation bezogen er will hier nicht
sagen dass wir Realität virtuelle
Realität oder Realität plus dass das
eine bloß Illusion sondern er möchte
sagen dass das
kompatibel ist mit perfekter Simulation
also vollständige Simulation in jeder
Hinsicht was glauben Sie mir diese
Fragen beantwortet
bis können wir wissen ob wir in einer
virtuellen Welt leben die jetzt eine
simuliert perfekt simulierte Welt ist
sind
virtuelle Welten real oder illusorisch
können wir ein gutes Leben einer
virtuellen Welt führen was denken Sie
was er dazu sagen wird
sie ahnen ist schon er sagt ja es sagt
zu jeder dieser Frage ja gehen wir mal
zurück er sagt
ja wir können es wissen
vor allem sagte zu diesem zweiten Punkt
virtuelle Welt sind real haben obwohl
sie simuliert sind unser dritten Frage
sagte auch ja wir können ein gutes Leben
in einer virtuellen Welt leben weil es
gibt nämlich Argumente die sagen in
einer virtuellen Welt
simulierten Welt
können wir gar keinen Wert Bewusstsein
entwickeln es geht nur in einer nicht
simulierten Welt das Beispiel ist das
wenn wir Pillen bekommen
glücklichkeitspillen
die uns die Welt als schön erscheinen
lassen hat die Welt dann ein wirklich
guten Wert angenommen wir bekam alles
solche Pillen
oder könnte man sagen ja aber solange du
die Pille nimmst also diese diese
illusionspille da hast du natürlich
keine kein wirkliches Wert Bewusstsein
sondern Simulation ja er sagt aber zu
allen diesen Fragen ja und das ist
erstmal etwas
philosophisch oder problematisch und er
tritt jetzt die Auffassung des virtual
Realist es sagt virtual realism
sie erinnern sich wer diesen Begriff
schon geprägt hatte virtual realison
Michael Heim mit seinem Buch und 1993
oder ein von 1998 das Buch von 1993 war
der Physiker
und Virtual Reality von 1998 er bezieht
sich darauf sagt Virtual Reality
reality ist
reality within
on the beautiful
wie Heim auf den er sich hier bezieht
sagte virtuelle Realität ist nicht
kompatibel mit
Illusion
soweit so gut die Frage die wir uns
jetzt aber bestellen weil wir damit da
kommt ist virtuelle Realität aber auch
kompatibel mit Simulation
und die Frage bejaht während ich und
hoffentlich wir sie verneinen wird als
mein Ziel ist es heute zu zeigen dass
virtuelle Realität natürlich kann man
sich sagen wir streiten jetzt uns über
wörtert oder Begriffe aber ich vertrete
die These das virtuelle Realität
konsequent verstanden ganz konsequent
verstanden nicht nur in kompatibel ist
mit
Illusion sondern auch in kompatibel ist
mit Simulation das ist meine These eher
hingegen sagt sie ist kompatibel mit
Simulation nicht direkt das sagt
jedenfalls nur sie ist inkompatibel mit
Illusion aber kompatibel mit Simulation
folgt daraus die wir noch sehen werden
in general ist the world
something is real someone ist
okay das ist klar jemand der glaubt
moralischen Raum existieren ist eine
moralische seine moralische Realistin
genauso auf diese anderen Punkte bezogen
jetzt müssen wir uns natürlich fragen ja
was versteht denn jetzt David Charme ist
bitte schön unter Realität daran hängt
jetzt kommt noch eine These also accept
Simulation Realist da sehen sie jetzt
deutlich er negiert die Kompatibilität
mit Illusion und virtuellen
die Kompatibilität mit Simulation als
ein Simulation Realist und jetzt kommt
einer Simulation okay
also gib ihm soweit recht dass ich sage
wenn wir seine Simulation befinden sind
die Objekte um uns herum keine Illusion
sondern Simulation
simulierte Objekte aber sind simulierte
Objekte real,-
ich hingegen würde argumentieren sind
nicht real,-
diskutieren der gleich drüber ich bringe
jetzt hier noch das Zitate zu Ende
gebaut wird schon reality genial
Simulation
Simulation Realistin
New Yorks Sydney Donald Trump in Beyoncé
und jetzt wollen wir mal ganz kurz
darüber diskutieren ich denke es gibt
genug Diskussionsstoff auf Basis dieser
Zitate
also wir haben gesehen David
sagt dass
Realismus Realität mit Simulation
kompatibel ist sofern sie inkompatibel
ist mit Illusion
natürlich muss man sich jetzt fragen was
versteht er unter Realität und was
versteht er unter Simulation prima Fazit
scheint ja Simulation immer vom Begriff
der Realität Unterschieden zu sein weil
simuliert ist immer nur die Wirklichkeit
mehr oder weniger exakt abbildet aber
nicht die Wirklichkeit ist ich habe ein
Beispiel gebracht wenn ich zu einer
Person sage ich wo jetzt so als ob ich
dich liebe simuliere dich zu lieben dann
würde die andere Person sofern man mit
ihr eine enge emotionale Verbindung hat
das als kein kommentieren und zwar
gerecht ja das sollte man möglichst
nicht sagen und auch schon gar nicht tun
wenn an einer ernsthaften Beziehung
gelegen ist
dann
haben wir jetzt hier weitere
Informationen von David nämlich be
wirklich der Kriterien für Realität was
ist denn jetzt eigentlich Realität er
bringt jetzt fünf Kriterien das ist
schon mal gut definieren definiert zwar
nicht virtuelle Realität das kritisiere
ich an ihm aber er definiert immerhin
Realität damit ist schon mal ein Anfang
gemacht
reality checklist spannender kann man
einfach so abhaken five questions to ask
when we will wondering weather aus not
something is real da sieht really X ist
univer
S
und jetzt sagte folgendes if via perfect
permanent Simulation
da haben wir jetzt einiges zu
diskutieren
wir sehen bezogen auf unsere bisherige
Definition und Annäherung an virtuelle
Realität
Kurse powers ist schon mal gut für
virtuelle Realität ja kausale Kräfte
Virtualität
virtualis ist etwas was mit Kausalität
zu tun hat
hier wird es jetzt schwierig
Unabhängigkeit von unserem
bloßen mentalen Zuständen ist schon mal
gut ja ist nicht nur subjektiv nicht
jeder hat seine private Welt
ihr seht es sieht also ist es wie es
scheint
da will er gegen die Illusion natürlich
sich abgrenzen ist ein echtes x auch das
hier really Existenz ist nicht eine Art
von
Zirkel er will doch gerade zeigen was
real ist jetzt fragte existiert es real
beißt sich da die Katze nicht in Schwanz
also ist es gar nicht irgendwie zirkulär
oder was auch immer ja darüber wollen
wir jetzt gleich ein bisschen noch
diskutieren ob sie die Kriterien
sinnvolle achten müssen natürlich auch
hier unten anschauen wenn wir in einer
perfekten permanenten Simulation
uns befinden
sind die Gegenstände die wir wahrnehmen
nach den oben genannten fünf Kriterien
real sind
also sagte eine perfekte permanente
Simulation ist dadurch dass alle fünf
Kriterien erfüllt sind ja
das nennt er Simulation reality müssen
dazu sagen eine perfekte permanente
Simulation perfekt heißt wir erkennen
nicht dass es eine Simulation ist das
war ihr Punkte gesagt hat permanent
heißt ist über unser ganzes Leben oder
jedenfalls in dieser Phase die zu
Debatte stehen die relevant ist
ja ähm darüber wollen wir jetzt gleich
diskutieren ob sie die Sekretärin
überzeugend halten für einen Begriff von
virtueller Realität
oder überhaupt Realität
ja wir haben gesehen diese Kriterien
sind teilweise ein bisschen
problematisch hier kommt der Begriff
really vor dabei soll das Kriterium
gerade uns erklären was real ist das
zirkulär die Frage muss aber dazu sagen
wenn es wirklich eine perfekte
permanente Simulation ist haben wir
keine Möglichkeit diesen Unterschied zur
Realität die simuliert wird wieder
geltend zu machen weil es ja eine
perfekte permanente nicht nur situative
oder irgendwie temporär beschränkte
begrenzte Simulation ist also Setting
ist schon so dass ja wir wir kein
Anhaltspunkt haben noch nach einer
zusätzlichen dahinter stehenden Realität
zu fragen man könnte natürlich Fragen
handelt es sich dann um eine Identität
die Identität des ununterscheidbaren
nach Leibnitz glaube ich nicht weil es
hier eben eine Simulation ist das ist
keine Identität Relation aber vielleicht
eine epistemische identitätsrillation
extremistisch macht keinen Unterschied
aber unter logisch schon und Leibnitz
wird eben eine unter ologische oder auch
logische Aussage treffen das macht er
nicht ist ein bisschen Schwäche
abgeschwächtigt Simulation ist ja auf
die systemische gehen sie auf der
systemischen Hinsicht identisch man so
will jetzt müssen wir aber mal die drei
ja
Existenzformen Simulation
Illusion genau anschauen
Virtualität so meine These muss
gleichermaßen von Simulation und fixon
unterschieden werden er versucht über
Simulation zu erklären er grenzt ab von
Illusion wie Michael
aber nicht wie germanya der hat gesagt
Illusion ist kompatibel damit ja muss
halt eine intersubjektive
Illusion sein in der subjektive
Drogentrip Simulationen modellieren
Realität nur während virtuelle
Realitäten
eigenen recht sind und eine eigene
Ontologie aufweist also ich glaube
Simulation greift zu kurz um von etwas
zu sagen das ist eine virtuelle Realität
ist die Tiefe Gegenstände benötigen
keine Referenz auf ein reales Vorbild
simulierte Gegenstände schon Simulation
braucht Referenz etwas wird simuliert
was real existiert
bei Fiktion ist es nicht so ja ich kann
zum Beispiel fingieren Harry Potter zu
sein
ich kann jetzt aber auch
lightsaber spielen und simulieren
dass ich eine Fiktion
betreibt weil ich kann auch fiktionale
Entitäten simulieren es gibt keine
Laserschwerter wirklich Laserschwerter
sind Bestandteil der fiktions Star Wars
es gibt Imitate Simulation
Replikate aber es gibt keine wirklichen
laserschwerte die genau dieselben
Eigenschaften haben sie wissen wie ein
Laserschwert bei Star Wars funktioniert
wenn Sie das Schwingen das erstmal
lassen Sie das hoch das geht vielleicht
noch aber da schneiden Sie sich den
Finger ab
es gibt vielleicht schon erste Ansätze
sowas mit Lasern zu machen sie können
sich mit dem Laser den Finger
abschneiden aber erzeugen sie meine
Laser Döner 80 cm aufhört der da so eine
Spitze hat ein Spitze geht nicht der
Lichtstrahl geht immer weiter den können
sie nicht einfach beschränken das ist
das erste Fiktion das zweite ist
versuchen Sie aber mit seinem Laser so
Kugeln zurück zu schießen oder so Laser
kommt es geht nicht es geht nicht ist
eine ganz klare Fiktion sie können aber
Fiktion simulieren sie können fiktive
Gegenstände nachbauen sie können sich
den Anschein geben so was zu haben wenn
dem es die Form hat die Geräusche die
wissen ja wie die Geräusche zustande
kamen das war Zufall ja
elektromagnetische Störer
stören haben zu diesem Geräusch geführt
was dann aber dafür eingesetzt wird sie
können das alles durch Soundchips
simulieren
Eigenschaften aber es ist ja noch eine
Simulation ja und Fiktionen sind eben
sowas dass sie keine Referenz haben auf
einem
reales oder auch nur fiktives das heißt
Simulationen müssen sich nicht auch ein
reales Vorbild beziehen sondern können
sich auch fiktives vorziehen aber das
fiktive wird dann irgendwie zum realen
der Simulation wir sind da wird Realität
und Fiktion irgendwie relativ lang sind
philosophische Gegenstände referieren
auf eine falsche Art und Weise auf ein
reales Vorbild zum Beispiel die Fata
Morgane ja natürlich ist diese Referenz
nicht ontologisch zu verstehen die da
von uns in der Wüste gesehene Oase
referiert nicht selbst auf eine Oase
sondern wir referieren wir konnotieren
Sie mit einer imaginären
Oase
genauso täuscht uns Messing nicht darin
dass es uns vormachen will Gold zu sein
Mittelalter gab es Theorie die sagten
Messing
lügenhaftes Material das täuscht uns und
sagt Gold ist es aber gar nicht
natürlich liegt natürlich im Gegenstand
sein uns ja ganz klar aber es hängt doch
noch mit diesem Objekt zusammen und
jetzt möchte ich Ihnen mal hier so eine
Klassifikation präsentieren und
natürlich wie immer zu Diskussion
stellen möchte jetzt mal hier Realität
unterscheiden in drei verschiedenen
Formen
es gibt physikalische Realität oder
physische mentale Realität aber auch
virtuelle Realität
physikalische physische Realität ist
eben ein Gegenstand der aus Materie
besteht ein wäre sowas häufig wird alle
Realität zumindest bei Kindern auf diese
Form von Realität bezogen
mir wurde damals beigebracht
ein
Substantiv ist alles dasjenige was ich
anfassen kann
der Stein
man hat mein Vater mich gefragt wie ist
es mit dem Wind
kann ich nicht anfassen ja man kann
natürlich auch fragen wie es mit dem
Gedanken ja kann ich den anfassen sie
sehen also die die
realitätsauffassung von Kindern sehr
stark auf physikalisch physisch
materielles bezogen mentale Realität
würden dann Leute zu geben die immer so
ein bisschen älter schon sind ja
Gedanken existieren ja wo sie irgendwie
subjektiv sind
wir haben Gründe wir haben Argumente wir
haben Dinge die uns im Gehirn sich
abspielen die nicht darin aufgehen dass
sie hier organische Zustände sind ja
Meinungen haben wir wir haben
Überzeugungen wir haben Gründe das
existiert alles der Grund existiert für
Sie dass Sie jetzt das und das machen
sonst würden sie es ja nicht machen das
ist mental
und jetzt glaube ich wir können auch
noch einen neuen Bereich dazu gesellen
nämlich den das virtuellen
und jetzt möchte ich aber noch
komplementär das Ganze durch ihre Formen
der Realität kontrastieren wir haben
Fiktionen Simulation und
Illusion
das macht jetzt natürlich David nicht
der sagt Simulation sind mit Realität
kompatibel
er hat hier nur Probleme mit
Illusion vielleicht auch mit Fiktion
aber mit Simulation perfekter
permanenter persistenter Simulation hat
David chamers kein Problem er spricht
von einem Simulation reality mich ist es
ein Widerspruch in sich aber man kann
natürlich so aus systemischer Hinsicht
argumentieren jetzt sehen wir wenn wir
uns jetzt die Serialität anschauen das
ist hier eine Steigerung gibt und zwar
von physikalischen hin zum mental das
mentale energiert auf dem physischen
zumindest bei uns ne ihre Gedanken die
haben sie nur durch ihr Gehirn also sie
brauchen damit sie ihre Gedanken haben
können fassen können und so weiter damit
die existieren brauchen Sie ein Gehirn
oder eine materielle Basis was man mal
offen ob vielleicht irgendwann auch
Maschinen denken können sie brauchen
eine materielle Basis auf denen die
Gedanken erst energieieren können jetzt
wird ontologisch das meine ich damit die
mentale Realität ist fundiert durch
physikalischen physische Realität durch
materiale Realität und genau so ist
jetzt virtuelle Realität fundiert durch
physische Realität durchaus durch
mentale Realität auch virtuelle Realität
wie zum Beispiel Banknoten oder Werte
von Banknoten die können nur dann
entstehen wenn es physisches gibt normal
das Papier kann man noch weiter spinnen
ins Computer gibt bei Bitcoins aber auch
wenn es mentales gibt ja kulturelle
Leistung ohne mentale Eigenschaften
können Sie keine virtuellen Realität
erzeugen wir sehen daraus virtuelle
Realitäten sind am aller
voraussetzungsvollsten von allen
realitätsformen die es gibt das sind
voraussetzungsvoller als bloß materiell
vorliegendes weil sie Bedürfnisse dürfen
dessen zugleich noch bedürfen noch der
mentalen Eigenschaften ja ich muss
natürlich Ideen haben ich muss mich
intersubjektiv einigen alles sozial
ontologische braucht mentale
Eigenschaften Metalle Entitäten also
virtuelle Realität ist sehr hochstufig
da brauchen wir momentan materielles was
existiert und mental ist und er ist auf
diese Basis kann das virtuelle Realität
entstehen
damit nicht genug es gibt auch noch
Modalitäten die habe ich Ihnen schon
anhand von Aristoteles kurz gezeigt
nämlich Notwendigkeit Möglichkeit und
Wirklichkeit und jetzt versuchen wir das
alles mal zusammenzuführen
virtuelle Realität
bezogen auf Realität auf Modalität und
auf Irrealität nicht ich glaube wir
bekommen eine ganz interessante Mischung
wir sehen nämlich dass
die Modalität der Möglichkeit mit der
Modalität der Fiktion auf eine gewisse
Art verwandt ist
fiktiv sind häufig Dinge die möglich
sind es gibt natürlich auch Fiktionen
von etwas was unmöglich ist
logisch unmöglich zumindest ja zum
Beispiel kann die könnte ich fingieren
dass eine das in einer Welt die Rechnung
1 und 1 nicht 2 gibt sondern drei das
ist an alle fiktiven Welt ist es
durchaus möglich ja fiktiven Welten
könnten Dinge der Fall sein die in
logischen möglichen Welten nicht der
Fall ist sie wissen nach Leibnitz in
einer möglichen Welt kann es keine
logische Widersprüche geben in einer
fiktiven Welt kann es aber logische
Widersprüche logisch Widersprüche
durchliche Dinge geben das heißt die
fiktionale Welt und die Möglichkeit oder
mögliche Welt sind nicht
identisch die die über die überlappen
sich teilweise damit will ich sagen
Detektive Welt ist größer als die Welt
der logisch möglichen Welten also der
Raum der logischen unmöglichen Welt ja
es gibt den großen Bereich des fiktiven
ich kann alles Mögliche figieren aber es
gibt eben auch im Bereich des fiktiven
Sätze
Fiktionen die logisch unmögliches
enthalten und dann sehe ich daran dass
die Menge aller fiktiven Welten größer
sein muss als die
Menge aller möglichen Welten zumindest
nach Leibnitz weil es gibt eben
Fiktionen die logische Widersprüche
enthalten es geht nicht also so ganz
koextensiv sind diese Mengen nicht ich
kann sie nicht einzeln aufeinander
abbilden aber sie enthalten sich
zumindest würde ich jetzt mal sagen
bilden enthalten auch die möglichen
Welten und jetzt sehen wir aber die
virtuelle Realität hat damit was zu tun
weil häufig
wir diese virtuelle und Realitäten in
der Diskussion in Kontexten von
Science-Fiction erleben ja vieles was
wir heute tatsächlich als virtuelle
Realität akzeptieren zum Beispiel das
metabär so wo wir virtuell interagieren
das ist ein virtueller Marktplatz das
war vor 50 Jahren Science Fiction ja das
heißt dieser fiktive Aspekt kommt
dadurch aus rein und es war natürlich
eine Möglichkeit die aber noch nicht
verwirklicht worden waren und jetzt
kommt noch was weiteres dazu
die virtuelle Realität bleibt eben nicht
bei der Möglichkeit sondern sie bringt
die Möglichkeit zu Wirklichkeit das
wiederum hängt zusammen mit dem
kraftaspekt und auch den kausalen Aspekt
des Wortes virtuell wir haben gesehen
virtuell ist halt so wie nicht
unmittelbar vorliegen etwas mit der
implizit enthalten sein und so würde ich
das auch auf die Fiktion beziehen es ist
nicht wirklich aktualis
möglich enthalten in irgendwas in der
Welt es kann aber durch die kausale
Kraft woher die auch immer kommt so
Wirklichkeit werden
gut es ist eine starke Tobak den ich
Ihnen hier präsentiere und damit möchte
ich eigentlich nur sagen dass
virtual Realität am Ende eine
Angelegenheit der Freiheit ist unsere
Freiheit hatten wir bei guter Weg schon
gesehen
er hatte auch gesagt Virtualität ist
nicht
etwas was wir reduzieren können zum was
auch wenn die Vernunft dazu kommt mit
unserer Freiheit zu tun hat und genauso
würde ich auch sagen virtuelle
Realitäten können wir nur dadurch
erzeugen dass wir kreativ sind dass wir
bestehendes auf eine neue Weise
teilweise durch Fiktionen durch den die
Erkundung der Möglichkeiten auf eine
neue Weise realisieren die eben genau
dieselben Zwecke erlaubt aber die durch
die z.B mediale Verfasstheit wie durch
die Digitalisierung sich unabhängig
macht von der materiellen physischen
Realität und eben gerade dadurch auch
neue Möglichkeiten eröffnet hier noch
ein bisschen weiter wir müssen jetzt uns
fragen wie verhalten sich physische und
virtuelle Realität zueinander hier
gibt's verschiedene Möglichkeiten
mindestens drei gestern habe ich die
schon kurz erwähnt wir können sagen die
physische und die virtuelle Realität
verhalten sich wie eine Verdoppelung
zum Beispiel wenn ich jetzt hier
irgendwie
adidas Schuhe habe und dann auch noch
NFC adidas Schuhe habe virtuelle Schuhe
ich bin damit ein bisschen unglücklich
war natürlich ist es kein virtueller
Schuh ich kann den ja nicht anziehen ich
habe ja nicht dieselbe Funktionen wie
bei einem wirklich Schuh deswegen halte
ich das nicht für sehr geeignet aber NFC
sind dennoch virtuelle Objekte weil es
ein Wert haben also auf Basis dieses
Wert Virtualität können wir noch 20
Token durchaus als virtuelle Objekte
ontologisch bestimmen ist es eine
Verdopplung ist eine Ersetzung dass die
virtuelle Realität die physische
Realität abschafft
disruptiv
auf den
Müllhaufen der Geschichte verdonnert
oder ist es eine Erweiterung meine These
ist
und kann hier alles diskutieren
eine Verdoppelung wird sich nicht lange
halten weil man muss sich entscheiden
irgendwann es ist schwierig immer eine
doppelwelt aufzuhalten aufrecht zu
erhalten das ist kostenintensiv das ist
Lebenswelt nicht praktisch wir brauchen
keine Verdopplung wenn der die
Funktionalität genau dieselbe ist das
heißt es würde dann seine Ersetzung
führen
wo möglich kann es zu Ersetzungen kommen
das sind Transformationen das sind
disruptionen das gibt's in verschiedenen
Bereichen erleben wir das vielleicht im
Filmgeschäft ja digitale Fotografie
erlaubt ganz neue Dinge digitale
Bücherei ersetzen vielleicht immer mehr
physische Büchereien es gibt natürlich
noch physische Bereiche aber ich würde
es ihr so sehen ist eine Erweiterung es
gibt also herkömmliche Material
gebundene Prozesse Institutionen
weiterhin aber da wo nötig dort wird das
Ganze virtualisiert zum Beispiel dann
wenn wir mal wieder eine corona-epidemie
haben ne da war das ziemlich hilfreich
virtuelle Bücherei zu haben natürlich
geht auch ein bisschen was verloren
unter Umständen persönlicher
körperlicher Kontakt wobei wir gesehen
haben dass das körperlich leibliche in
der virtuellen Realität so wie sie
technologisch zum Beispiel von Apple
konzipiert wird wieder reingeholt werden
zu unserer Körper wird zu Medium der
virtuellen Realität indem wir zum
Beispiel durch Gesten uns im Cyberspace
navigieren
ja das möchte zu bedenken geben und
jetzt möchte ich natürlich eine auf der
Hand liegende Kritik
einbeziehen wenn wir gesehen haben das
virtuelle Realität zu abhängig ist
sondern der materiellen Realität dank
Note müssen Papierstück haben von der
mentalen Realität da muss jemand auf die
Idee kommen das noch mal Geld überhaupt
erfinden soll das heißt wir brauchen
Gedanken mentale Realität dann heißt es
doch eigentlich dass virtuelle Realität
total abhängig ist von physischer und
eben mentaler Realität existiert sie
dann überhaupt wirklich und das hat
jetzt Jeff maupass ein ja Medien
Philosoph kritisiert er sagt the virge
das not constitute
kritisiert solche Auffassung das
virtuelle Entitäten Dinge da irgendwo
rum schweben wird als seien sie autonom
ja spricht sogar dann noch von einer
Case und contential dependents of the
virtual on the nonversion das non
virtual wäre zum Beispiel mentales und
physisches
und er kommt sogar zu dem wie ich finde
problematischen Urteil der Sack be
virtual das not introduce any special
Lieder problems
it are pitch
also das virtuelle führt nicht zu neuen
ethischen oder legalen Problemen die
spezifisch für das virtuelle allein
gelten ich glaube schon ich glaube schon
und zwar deswegen weil eben die Raum und
zeitlogik sich in der Wirtschaft
Realität ändert und wie im heutigen
Rechtssystem sehen dass das digitale
große Probleme macht manche Phänomene
wie im metaver zu machen für das
Rechtssystem große Problem
Eigentumsverhältnis und so weiter
Rechtsverletzungen Interaktion überhaupt
Verhalten im virtuellen Raum
medial vermittelt das macht große
Probleme für das Rechtssystem und
deswegen stimme ich ihm hier nicht so
ich stimme darin zu dass das virtuelle
nicht wird das ich spreche ihr von
virtuelle Realität ist die virtuelle
Realität nicht so autonom zu verstehen
ist dass sie unabhängig von mentalen
oder auch Material oder medial
Prozessen existiert natürlich ist das
alles abhängig ziehen die ziehen Sie den
Stromstecker schneiden Sie das große
Internetkabel im Atlantik durch und Sie
werden sehen was da noch alles von den
virtuellen Objekten bleibt das war ja
auch die Frage wie lange existieren die
sind hochgradig abhängig hochgradig
anfängt aber auch unsere Gedanken sind
hochgradig abhängig und hochgradig ja
verletzlich wenn jemand kommt und uns
plötzlich das Gehirn ausschalten ja
passiert hoffentlich nicht so häufig
aber wenn wir eine Kugel im Kopf
bekommen dann war es auch mit den
Gedanken ja also das heißt nicht das ist
dass die Gedanken nicht irgendwie
weniger Existenz sein nur weil unsere
Gehirn irgendwann mal ein Geist aufgeben
kann genauso kann auch der wird völlig
Geist irgendwann den Geist aufgeben wenn
man eben den Strom absteht und es
stellten das Internet Kabel
durchschneiden ja also die Existenz von
virtuellen Objekten wird nicht dadurch
eingeschränkt ihre Ontologie dadurch
dass sie abhängig sind von verschiedenen
anderen Strukturen überhaupt nicht
unsere Gedanken sind total abhängig
dennoch existieren Gedanken würde ich
sagen sie existieren davon dass wir
genug zu nahe zu essen bekommen essen
sie mal zwei Wochen lang nichts da
werden sie keine Gedanken mehr haben
oder zumindest keine klaren Gedanken ja
also genau dasselbe kann man in meinen
Augen auf dem Gedanken sein und dennoch
würde niemand bestreiten das ist keine
Gedanken gibt
er sagte eben nicht dass es keine
virtuellen Realitäten gibt es sagt eben
nur sie sind gar nicht abhängig das
stimmt aber ich sehe das nicht als eine
Einschränkung ihrer Ontologie ja und
auch diesen letzten Punkt bestätigt das
virtuelle hat gravierende Problem
gravierende Probleme für uns unsere
Ethik und für unsere Rechtssystem sich
ja das heißt die Abhängigkeit virtuelle
Realität von denen sie erzeugenden
materiellen oder mentaloren bedeutet
keinesfalls eine ontologische nach oder
im Gegenteil ich glaube das virtuelle
Realität ontologisch höherstufig ist als
materielles und mentales weil es beide
voraussetzt es kann nur auf deren Basis
existieren also muss es höherstufig sein
theologisch das heißt nicht das ist
irgendwie dauerhafte Wert es wird
dadurch weil es hörstufig ist abhängige
ja aber auch unsere Gedanken unsere
Gedanken als Entität sind natürlich viel
viel verletzlich und abhängiger als die
Lebensfunktion eines Regenbogens ja oder
einer einer möge Jungs ja das existiert
ist teilt sich und so weiter unsere
Gedanken sind hochgradig verletzlichen
zum Glück nicht so verletzlich wie eine
clouds oder ein Metaversum was irgendwie
den Geist aufgibt wenn man da mal viele
Stromkabel zieht aber wir können uns
natürlich auch das Stromkabel ziehen
wenn wir nichts mehr essen das sehe ich
eine ganz klare Analogie dazwischen wir
kommen gleich zu Diskussion ich möchte
ein paar Thesen bringen die Tatsache das
virtuelle Realität en auch
physikalischen oder physischen
materiellen Realitäten energieieren
jetzt habe ich schon den Begriff der
immer ergänzt gebracht den muss ich noch
genauer erklären bedeutet
anders sich dabei um ontologisch
hörstufige Entitäten hat die sind
voraussetzungsvoller was ihre
konstitutionsbasis angelangt wie aber
müssen jetzt fragen hängen physische und
virtuelle Realität genommen
als wir sehen
100-Euro-Schein
was sie ist ein Schein ein Papier das
ein Wert hat die virtuelle Realität ist
der Wert
und der ist unabhängig von dem
materiellen Wert des Papiers wie hängen
jetzt papierschalen der kein Wert hat
oder vielleicht Wert von zwei Center und
50 Cent hat mit den 100 € zusammen die
dieser Schein Wert ist also wie
verhalten sich materielle Wert der
Schein nunmateriell betrachtet und der
Schein als Geldschein betrachten wie
verhalten die sich zueinander sind sie
identisch
offenbar nicht weil dann hätte der Geld
schon einmal den werden einmal nicht
dann wäre zugleich 50 Cent wert und
zugleich 100 € wird das heißt die das
Papier
allen Eigenschaften die auch der
100 Euro Schein hat
können nicht identisch sein das ist ein
bisschen schwieriger
ich habe schon gesagt das wird die
virtuelle Realität hängt mit der
physischen Realität insofern zusammen
als sie auf ihr energiert was heißt
jetzt Energie das bedeutet nicht dass
sie nur diese virtuelle Realität nur aus
ihr energieren kann das ist keine andere
materielle oder sonstige Basis gäbe auf
der diese Realität zum Beispiel dieser
Wert 100 € Energie geben könnte so es
lassen sich anderes Szenarien Denken in
welche dieselbe wie virtuelle Realität
auf eine andere materiellen Basis
Energie das nehme ich die multiple
mediale Realisierbarkeit des virtuell
sie haben bestimmt schon mal gehört die
multiple Realisierbarkeit des mentalen
in der Philosophie des Geistes bei
Hillary Partner oder Jerry Foto auch
schon mal gehört das sind Philosophen
das Geistes die sagen bestimmte Hirn
bestimmte Qualen ja wie zum Beispiel
Freude kann ich durch die oder Schmerz
genau gesagt die kann auch Schmerz
springen kann ich durch ganz
verschiedene
Verletzungen erzielen ich kann die
c-phasen reizen aber es ist auch
durchaus möglich dass eine andere Region
gereizt wird und genau dasselbe
Schmerzempfinden mental auftreten das
heißt es gibt keine Identitätstheorie
wir können nicht sagen der Schmerz ist
identisch mit der Aktivierung dieses
gehirnarreals und nur mit dieses mit
diesen sondern wir können das selbe
Phänomen mental durch verschiedene
organische Stimulationen oder Prozesse
realisieren und genauso können wir
natürlich den Wert 100 € auf
verschiedene weiße realisieren wir tun
als Bitcoin als ein 10.000 Bitcoin keine
Ahnung oder 1000 Bitcoin und ich tausend
vielleicht 150 Bitcoin keine Ahnung
wir können aber auch die 100 €
realisieren durch ein Check ja wo ich
drauf schreibe wir können ihn
realisieren durch einmal ein Mark Stücke
ja gibt ganz verschiedene materiellen
materielle Basel auf den wir denselben
Gürteln wird realisieren
flexibel was die Realisierung derselben
Realität angenommen
das Geld habe ich schon bezahlt gezeigt
die Flexibilität des Geldes als man
spricht auch von der ontologischen
Flexibilität des Geldes die zeigt sich
darin dass es eben gleichermaßen durch
Papier aber auch durch digitale Technik
realisiert werden kann ja es ist
flexibel allerdings ist die ontologische
Flexibilität des Geldes nur ein
notwendiges kein hinreichendes Kriterium
wird dessen virtuelle Realität da muss
noch was dazu kommen das reicht nicht zu
sagen ich kann so oder so realisieren
warum wird es überhaupt auf diese Basis
welche Art auch immer sie sein
realisieren
stellen Sie die Frage was genau der
Grund dafür ist dass es in einem Fall
ein Stück Papier
ein Objektiv Realwert hat für 100 € und
im anderen Fall nicht zum Beispiel
oder überlegen Sie zu einer bestimmten
Zeit hat ein Papier einen bestimmten
Wert seine bestimmten Zeit nicht wenn
sie Geld aus dem Jahr 1900 haben hat es
nicht mehr diesen Wert
inflationsbereinigt den es damals hat
wenn sie unter Reichsmark haben dann
hätte das inflationsbereinigt vielleicht
wird von weiß nicht 500 x 5 oder mal
sehen ich weiß nicht den Faktor 130 Mark
Schein hat heute vielleicht ein Wert von
Sammlerwert von vielleicht
10 5 keine Ahnung wenn es dann noch die
Inflationszeit war um 1920 herum und
haben sie 100 Millionen Schein sie sehen
es hängt immer auch ab von der Zeit in
der diese Schein einen Wert hatte
natürlich müssen wir uns fragen warum
hattet ihr jetzt einen Wert zu dieser
Zeit ja das müssen wir uns auch fragen
es wird die Frage nach dem Bedingungen
auf unter denen auf einer materiellen
technisch digitalen Basis eine virtuelle
Realität überhaupt energieren kann was
immer ganz genau bedeutet und jetzt
möchte ich Ihnen konkretes Beispiel
bringen in der neueren analytischen
Ontologie analytisch meint hier die
durch Begriffsanalyse
geprägte Philosophie die häufig geben
angelsächsischen Bereich prominentes
zunehmend auch in München hier an dieser
schönen diese analytischen Philosophie
und Ökologie hat die leider im Jahr 2017
Verstorbenen Baker die war übrigens auch
mal hier in München ich mache oben
rechts den Link rein zu dem Video wenn
es das noch gibt auf youtube hat sie
einen Vortrag gehalten über Personen
also ganz wichtige ontologin und sie hat
um zeigen was Konstitution ist sie
spricht mich von einer Konstitution hat
sie das Phänomen des Geldes verwendet um
das zu explizieren
sie kommt nicht direkt auf in ihrer
Philosophie auf das Phänomen der
virtuellen Realität zu sprechen das
behandelt sie nicht aber wir können eben
an Beispiel des Geldes von dem wir
wissen dass es ein Fall von
virtualidität ist genauer verstehen wie
es dazu kommt dass es existiert wie es
also konstituiert wird sie hat eine ganz
bekannte Theorie verfasst oder mit
mitgeprägt entscheidend die sich
konstitutions-relation das ist die
Relation zwischen der materiellen Basis
zum Beispiel dem Papier des Geldscheins
und dem Wert des Geldscheins ist eine
Relation des virtuelle und das worauf es
Energie ist besteht da besteht eine
Relation der Konstitution als eine
perversive Relation die unsere gesamte
Lebenswelt durchgehen sagt also ganz
rekulturelle Welt ist durch
konstitutionsverhältnisse
charakterisiert eine general Idee of
Constitution ist besser
newcastings mit
Newcastle Systems
Konstitution ist
of paper constitute
Flex pieces of France
also Stücke von
Stoff konstituieren eine Flagge
uns interessiert jetzt vor allem das
hier Papierstücke Scheine konstituieren
Dollarnoten mit einem objektiven Wert
und das glaube ich können wir sehr gut
nutzen um uns zu erklären wie genau
virtuelle Realität abhängt von der
materiellen Basis oder auch von der
mentalen Basis von der darunter
stehenden
Schicht
entscheidend ist jetzt für die
Konstitution einer Entität sei es jetzt
eine virtuellen Entität was auch immer
der spezifische Kontext innerhalb dessen
etwas konstituiert werden kann wenn er
singt sagt sie auf one primary Kind
zirkusen Kind
Kausalität was wiederum sehr gut zum
Begriff der Virtualität passt jetzt sagt
sie natürlich ist insurgents das ist
natürlich etwas vage ja wenn als etwas
in bestimmten geeigneten Umständen ist
ein Papierstück dann bekommt es den Wert
aber nur wenn die geeigneten Umstände
der falls sie spricht hier von einer
Kauf von kausalen Kräften die im ganzen
Sinne der Bedeutung von Virtualität
durch bestimmte Umstände auf ein
Phänomen übergehen wie der Wert eine
Banknote auf Basis eines bloß bedruckten
Platzes Papier welches hier durch und
das sind jetzt die geeigneten Umstände
die surfen stand durch ein
intersubjektive Gemeinschaft und Regeln
Verbindlichkeiten Objektivität erlang
zum Beispiel durch die Europäische
Zentralbank zum Beispiel durch unsere
Wahl waren zum Beispiel durch unsere
Verfassung an der wir irgendwie doch
auch beteiligt sind ja ohne dass wir uns
jetzt genau auf den Wert hier mal
geeinigt haben aber wir sind irgendwie
dran beteiligen und das ist genau diese
intersubjektive Gemeinschaft durch die
am Ende etwas konstituiert sie spricht
mit Blick auf diese konstituierenden
Umstände die sie genendt davon dass sie
zwar notwendig jedoch nicht hinreichend
sind für die Konstitution einer
bestimmten Entität F erst dann wenn sich
ein geeignetes F sich in den Umständen
gehe befindet wenn sich da enthalten ist
wird es zugekonstitutioniert also ich
kann jetzt nicht alles sagen unter den
geeigneten Umständen zu einem Geldschein
machen ja es geht nicht sagt sie ich
könnte zum Beispiel nicht
wenn man ein Beispiel vielleicht ein
kleiner irgendwie zum Geld werden lassen
es geht vielleicht nicht ja es muss auch
noch das richtige Medium sein was
zusätzlich mit dem geeigneten bestimmt
dann so virtuellen Realität wird oder
ein Wert bekommt ja ich könnte mir auch
andere Dinge überlegen
man sieht aber allerdings dass das Geld
ziemlich flexib ist dass wir fast jedes
F nehmen können weil Geld eigentlich
sich also der Wert sich an fast jedem
materielle Basis binden löst denken Sie
an Muscheln die auch teilweise als
Zahlungsmittel verwendet wurden also bei
Geld glaube ich können wir als zuerst
fast alles einsetzen und es wird
konstituiert wie diskutieren gleich
genau noch weiter all das möchte ich
einfach nur zur vorstellen
und jetzt wenden wir das ganze auf
virtuelle Realität an dann sehen wir
dass die Eignung von 11 im Falle von
virtuelle Realität in seiner medialen
Struktur begründet sein
also sicherlich Geld ist eine virtuelle
Realität aber auch das Medium der Schein
oder und so weiter muss irgendwie eine
Eigenschaft aufweisen die es
zur emergence des Wertes bringen lässt
z.B auf der Gegenstand nicht sein was
befließt oder bei der Berührung vergeben
es muss ein materieller Gegenstand sein
der eine gewisse Härte das Stabilität
hat Muscheln eignen sich das sehr gut
dazu ja was sie nicht machen können ist
zum Beispiel
ein Stückchen Butter
ja ein Stückchen Butter das wird zerlauf
sie können ein tiefgefrorenes Stückchen
Butter Versuchen zur Währung zu machen
das zerrinnt uns zwischen den Händen das
verliert seine Identität es müssen Dinge
sein die ihre Identität durch den Wandel
und wechselt der des Mediums behalten
das ist Medium ein gefrorenes Stück
Butter geht nicht weil wenn ich das in
der Hand habe oder in der Hosentasche
habe dann ist es sehr laufen ein
Geldschein geht aber auch nicht jedes
Papier geht sie wissen die Euro
Banknoten sind stabil die müssen in sich
eine Stabilität besitzen sie können da
nicht irgendwie
Küchenpapier benutzen ja oder so das
muss das muss in sich stabil sein da
sehen sie ist nicht trivial aber für
Geld Verwehrung können Sie alles
eigentlich ziemlich viel nehmen was
irgendwie hart ist ein stabil ist ja
man kann ja noch dazu sagen was
vielleicht nicht so leicht zu fällen ist
ja muss man auch dazu sagen sie können
irgendwie ein Stück Toilettenpapier da
als Geld benutzen seitdem in
corona-zeiten aber sonst geht es
eigentlich nicht ja also sie sehen es
muss irgendwie schon auch
fälschungssicher sein sprich es muss
sich davor selbst schützen
das ist der sinnlosen Simulation und der
illusions
das kann schon auch in der materiellen
Basis begründet sein so jetzt haben wir
sehr viel geredet jetzt möchte ich zum
Schluss heute noch eine Diskussion über
diese sehr ja voraussetzungsvoll Thesen
gerne mit ihm starten